bist du ein wildes kätzchen servus s
kids und herzlich willkommen tsum bambi
wird heute zusammen mit max und schaut
mal dieses bild an leute gucken mal
einfach dass dieses bild hier auf mich
wirken der leute ich habe ein neues
objektiv gekommen die kamera und ich
weiß nicht was mir so gefallen aber
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
begeben wir uns auf den schritt von der
demokratie netz begeben wir uns nun auf
den weg der uns zielgerichtet zum
heutigen video führen wir machen heute
nämlich eine versuche dich nicht zu
schämen challenge ganz kurz doch für
alle die sich fragen okay was ist das
ist im prinzip wie 2008 nur dass es
nicht darum geht nicht zu lachen sondern
wir schauen uns peinlich videos aber man
darf sich nicht für das was im video
passiert schämen sonst haben wir
verloren
jetzt komme ich mit einem video
einbringen was für mich der inbegriff
von sich fremdschämen ist und ja ich
mache mir ist heute dieses video so
schlimm aber lassen wir das eine strafe
aus denken okay was mache so der
verlierer muss eine passage aus diesem
video das jetzt kommt nach stellen in
der eu aber ohne erklärung ok solange
hier kann das und das und dann kommt
einfach trocken was aus dem video die
fragen beziehen plätzen video behälter
verpackt hat muss max feiert soll aber
über es gibt sie die villa feiert sein
heutiger was ist wieso ist das denn ja
ok ich hab' verkackt hier
der punkt geht an dich die first call st
sie sollen abstimmen
ich glaube er hat sich selbst auch nicht
besonders wohl gefühlt bei geht also mit
niedrigen schultern so der brauchte ja
bitte hast du einfach innerlich sowie
das du dir gibt ja diesen
gesichtsausdruck
das kennt man
[Musik]
das lustige ist dass war ich so in dem
alter wie ich war nämlich einmal in
einem hotel wo man sich so alles
bestellen konnte auch seine zimmer karte
übrigen unterlagen habe ich so vier oder
fünf red bull getrunken mit neun jahren
und sollte die ganze nacht nicht
schlafen besser das ist meine hymne
älter
[Musik]
du kennst kannst du eine rückkehr zu den
scheiß schon wieder ich habe immer so
eine youtube playlist da waren ganz
viele von den videos in
in so einer generierten playlist habe
ich keine ahnung auch so diese ist
dieses mal interview nun bei er hat ein
gutes potenzial allerdings heraus dass
an dem bild sind auch die das fresh ich
habe mal gar nichts sagen dienstag
[Musik]
dollar geeinigt haben dringenden
arzttermin du machst du weiter wird ich
muss für seine werkstatt quasi auto war
dass ich bin geblieben
damit steht es 3 zu 2 diesmal hat man
sich auch aus anklagen lassen hier
blumen schrecken international hotel
einfach
sie hat dieses jahr 20 mal den stücken
nein das ist so
geisteskrankheit mich ist dieser moment
hattest du das nicht mal weiß wir am
bahnhof fahren
sie hatten eine ähnliche situation heute
ich war im urlaub und war dann auf dem
rückweg am bahnhof ja wenn man im urlaub
in diesen bahnhof und max aber so eine
rote jacke wachstum gerade bist du dich
gegen gesprungen ist oder zu machen oder
das kleine jungs und wie gesagt max hat
eine rote jacke an und dann läuft von
mir so eine person roten jacke ich denke
das mag es brennt so von hinten auf sie
zu und bringen diese von hinten quasi an
und umarmt und wieso und wird was aber
irgendwie angriffen nie gesehen da wär
ich brauche erstmal dankeschön dafür und
ich ich dann zog eine art 50
mitarbeiterinnen und schaue mir das
etwas anders mit okay leute eine story
habe ich noch und zwar war das auch im
urlaub da müsst ihr wissen ist so ein
café was im ersten stock zum balkon hat
ja und von diesem balkon schaut man raus
und platz und auf den balkonen oben
saßen so zwei erwachsenen eltern von
ihrem kind und ich stand unten
man hat doch unten etwas gemacht hat
diesen platz wurde auf einmal winken
diese runter und ich dachte mir so ich
kenne ich gar nicht aber was machst du
dann allerdings zurück
ich kenne viele verwechseln zurück wenn
ich drehe mich um steht so denken wir
nicht unsere umgedreht aber leute ja die
heutige challenge habe ich leider
verloren weil max kanadischen max ist
einfach eiskalt bei so was das heißt ich
werde in meinem nächsten video eventuell
was einbauen folgendes sagen sag mal was
ging erwähnt dass der mann so zerrissen
ich sage dazu nichts mehr leute schon
das nächste video erwarten macht es
natürlich auch eine beschreibung
verdient und bis zum nächsten mal